come on just talking about Bill Cosby
yeah and how the trial started yesterday
yeah yeah creepy two days ago or two
days ago days ago and they're giving
just testimony they learn creepy listen
yeah still funny though it is and I
believe them but I just don't understand
taking a pill with someone gives it to
you like like I would I guess care about
cos he said I don't know I know but I
just can't picture taking anything if
someone says here take this I wouldn't
do it but if it were go right back with
blaming the victim yeah I know about
certain I also got raped
I'm [ __ ] with you know like I even
said it before like I'm not saying they
deserve to hear it's just a stupid silly
it's a dangerous thing to do you're
putting some in a dangerous place so
just get did you know you're in this
business remember the first time I
famous comedian just walked up to you
and said you were funny yeah you would
you wait for that night I was so excited
the first time that happen I just I you
know III can definitely see how like ya
get input she knew him for 18 months
like she knew it for 18 months they had
like relationships with everything like
oh so she trusted him and she wanted to
maintain that relationship yeah I got
Bill Cosby is I do understand yeah I
just can't picture myself taking a
pillage it's just too scary
well what reasons back then I you know
that's what they get all yourself take
this you know right there are
interrelated and relaxes you know what I
whenever I watched old Hollywood movies
I'm like morbidly going IMDB does
everything have to have a [ __ ]
picture with the two weeks film or do
you need is like [ __ ] nine tortoise
now he's not chatting snapchatting
[ __ ] these just a lot of different
ways to hit is these days we gotta hit
him on every day not really there's a
lot of a lot of medium of possibility by
Native Americans that are too [ __ ]
tourists urea where the satellite radio
these people's being stolen they act
like you're crazy though if you're not
on all forms of social media they're
like I need an Instagram it I'm like why
we tried to we filmed it for you - I
know [ __ ] with snapchat I like things
saved I don't like things that
disappeared bothers me I like to like
look at something and be able to save it
and enjoy I don't like that they say it
disappears and then somebody just
screenshots and it's like no it did well
they can tell you disagree it's it's
[ __ ] that you don't give a [ __ ] about
disappears but other stuff yeah that
prevents you Jim from someday being the
next president makes they don't hang
around
I've never sent a photo that my with my
face about that was bad have you ever in
all the years like I know you do it your
girl for a long time have you ever sent
anything out that you're like oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have sent that were you always
pretty smart with texting and stuff like
that
oh no not not texting or that [ __ ] no I
haven't been smart called Jimmy come on
how long you know you know I haven't
been smart and it's but I have no plans
of running for public office or protest
protesting anything significant so they
don't give a [ __ ] like all my [ __ ] saved
in some [ __ ] hard drive under the
Pentagon they're never going to need to
use it it is it is yeah yeah just a just
in case file but it's never ends every
guy makes a left turn it's just like I
know I'm a dope I am a part of the
masses you know I still think this is my
creative people hate my talk about our
technology some day any text that we've
sent is going to be able to be
retrievable some future technology we'll
be able to go back and get every bit of
electronic communication today no but I
mean they can't go back and just say it
me and bill sent a text to five years
ago and both of our phones are destroyed
but we sent it through somehow there's
gonna be a way to go back and get all
that technology someday who wants to do
that and why it'll be it'll be like two
true biographies of people like they're
going to go back just to do it they're
going to have the technology to do it
and go back and grab all of these things
that they can now grab I don't know how
they're going to do it but you know when
you send something out what's to prevent
them from just making [ __ ] up nothing
new or nothing but I mean like some day
like you know when you send out a TV
signal it just goes forever anticipate
there's going to be a way to capture all
those texts that got sent out or all
those messages and emails that got sent
out electronic you think they're going
to get it from space I don't know how
they'll do it but there will be a way to
grab it someday maybe hundred years from
now and they're going to go back and
have true biographies of people and all
these things that we think we're saying
privately are not going to be private it
can be like who cares that was a hundred
years ago yeah agree but they will do it
I don't understand people's obsession
with like wanting to know all that stuff
you know I don't know if it's just is it
to me I kind of am curious about it
myself I don't mean individuals or
companies because like companies collect
every bit of data humanly possible no no
I just mean like why people want to know
what the [ __ ] neighbors
texting to somebody like why would
college individuals yeah what was the
technology there people will just do it
because it's there it's almost when you
look through an attic like just looking
they won't even be any real reason for I
think people just do it out of curiosity
yeah I get curious I mean yeah the same
reason why like you know somebody had
their window open and I wasn't doing
anything I would just watch what they
were doing ha ha ha I just yeah I don't
get that I just I I don't know it's like
when I watch like you know watch all
these sports channels now they're always
talking about the [ __ ] drama behind
the [ __ ] thing and it's just saying I
don't care who won the game oh you're
not interested in any of the [ __ ] and
then everything that [ __ ] happens he
got arrested for this good he got
arrested the police and the bail take
care take care of it yeah do you care
like we at Lou Piniella and recently so
I was dying to know about like those
altercations between Reggie and Thurman
Munson and Billy Martin and all that
crazy stuff that was happening like I
kind of liked that for some reason you
don't you don't care about that at all
ya know I don't know why I do you just
just the game for you yeah I don't yeah
I still do look you want to talk about
this guy said this is this said that to
a guy and then they had a fist you saw
like a fist fight on the field maybe but
I don't uh yeah no I don't actually who
did like a Raj dating JLo I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah that I don't care
yeah leave him alone like the fact
remember Robbie Alomar spit in the
umpires face yeah and then like there
was rumors no one knows if it's true
there was rumors that Robbie Alomar was
gay at the time it was a rumor and that
he Empire had made some disparaging or
anti-gay remark and he spit at him and
that's why the whole thing went away
because the umpire said all these weird
I would love to know what that was about
I would love to know why he spit in the
face of an umpire and wasn't in more
trouble
yeah the fighting interest me always
even if it's behind-the-scenes I want to
know what the tensions about bio
actually well I I for a while ago was
pitching at the NFL or one of these
sports network should have like a rated
our network and all the players are
miked up but the thing about it in so
you could hear what they say during the
plays but then you know they just the
liability for the league this [ __ ] that
the [ __ ] that people would be saying
during the during the game I don't think
that that would work
that's a great idea yes I'm just joking
my spectacle I'm hoping like in the
future though that people like they just
get I don't know I don't think they're
gonna be I think it's just going to be
fascinating watching you're going to
spend your life watch another reading
what other people tweeted and [ __ ]
watching people on yeah dude I think my
wife watched she just like it's becoming
like a thing like we go to bed at night
and it's just like I can't watch any
more of these [ __ ] shows where
someone's trying to get married
Bachelorette on TV yeah I can't watch
any of these [ __ ] shows where it's
like five women in red-bottom shoes
calling each other [ __ ] yeah I just
how many how long can you fight this is
this is like the I find it depressing
what do you think the attraction to it
is uh I don't know I think it's like
they're sports
it's just mindless you know why do i
watch sports why do I give a [ __ ] about
the Cavaliers game tonight I give a [ __ ]
I want to see them win I want to see you
know the pylon team get beat I want to
see that I don't like just mindless but
it's so [ __ ] care about I guess but I
don't know I I don't I think it's going
to get more because I get you look at
what like kids grow up watching now and
it's just stuff on YouTube where people
are literally doing nothing like don't
just a little kid is growing up watching
somebody unbox toys like that's what
kids like wandering on YouTube unboxing
sense right opening a little Asian stuff
there and they just watch for hours I've
seen them they're like like three and
four-year-olds just sit there on YouTube
for hours watching people unbox
something and there's no ways like that
that curiosity just stays in you so that
that becomes entertainment I just feel
like [ __ ] accepting everybody is
event and be like wow you know [ __ ]
this in the future there's just going to
be like no privacy and and just that's
just how it's going to be if you're not
doing nothing wrong I mean what the
problem with all of that [ __ ] it's
literally going to be that the the
ability to revolt against something
oppressive is going to discontinue
because they're going to know who's
doing it and they're going to know how
to stop it there probably will be no
money anymore you'll be [ __ ]
microchip they can just shut your
microchip off so you got no money to
fund whatever the [ __ ] it is you're
trying to do they can either take you
out literally or they
just go back and splice together the
worst [ __ ] tweets you ever sent I
mean nobody's gonna [ __ ] survive that
we really hope to have the [ __ ] that I
texted to Rosa jokingly like you know
they that alone could stop me for
running from any [ __ ] public office
you hope though that with that
technology that can [ __ ] people like
that it also knocked people who can do
it down to a normal level like I think
that technology also [ __ ] people in
power because they're now also it's so
easy to find out the stuff they're doing
yeah but those are that you know those
are the clowns all of those [ __ ] guys
that are like in in power than that in
power those [ __ ] guys make they make
no [ __ ] money the president makes
five hundred grand a year makes no
[ __ ] money then these the 200grams
yes you have to 504 509 a [ __ ] year
and it costs like a hundred million to
get it like all of those guys like you
know what he looks like you know what
your senator looks like an all that [ __ ]
but you don't know what like you know
these heads of corporations look like
nobody's going to be [ __ ] looking at
those guys I don't think or they'll own
the technology and then yeah scrub this
whoever's coming up with that [ __ ] it's
going to go back and scrub the [ __ ] out
of their own stuff first I would think
it just I don't know but by then I think
the robots will be here I think before
that technology comes out the robots
will take over how do you feel that like
they did the only NSA leaks and stuff
and like a lot of stuff is coming out
like people just who have access to it
now just kind of spinning it out
therefore I don't necessarily mind it
the NSA leaks coming out no I mean as
long as people even people who we're
helping us are being killed I kind of
don't mind seeing it like you kind of
feel like it's eventually going to force
people to be more accountable or honest
if all this stuff is going to be leaked
out I feel like the stuff is getting
leaked out though it's just the tip of
the iceberg mo just gonna jump in
getting the is the person is going to
get hurt as a little guy always gets
hurt the big guys they'll they'll figure
out a way around it and they'll they
have the money to spin it a certain way
and say like a Snowden guy's evil he was
going to help people out he's Pro this a
product they have the ability you know
like I don't know if what they're saying
about that guy is true or it isn't true
but I all I have is their [ __ ]
version of who the [ __ ] guy is so
congratulations is really deep by the
way I came here to promote a cartoon
where happened congratulations efforts
for family season two is out it's up the
streaming that
uh-huh and how you feeling I'm feeling
great man I'm getting we're getting all
kinds of positive feedback from
everybody people seem to be liking it
better than the first season thank
Christ and you know it's a ton of work
and you know we finally get it done as
people go ahead I kind of sucked and you
know they're like oh man there's a waste
of a year in my life so very excited
good man they like the first season you
like all the said you don't want to look
at the second season and be disappointed
so they like it more that's that's a
great thing yeah and you know do the
show with the great Mike Price from
other Simpsons and now we got all these
people on from the first season laura
dern justin long Sam Rockwell Dave
Koechner Haley Reinhart Debi Derryberry
mo Collins I want to make sure I give us
many people shout out as I can remember
and then we've added some more people TJ
Miller came on this CD is great yeah
it's always amazing and what's his name
I think I just spaced on his name he
played home on the wire
Oh Michael K yes thank you um he came on
and did a voice I didn't get to meet him
though
you know just how that works even though
had scenes with him I was out in LA and
he was out here
oh they record yeah okay he [ __ ]
crushed it it's been great it's been
great so there's ten you know first
season we only get like six episodes I
think they kind of want to see sure so
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then now we get
ten so that's awesome dude I've been
crediting you you convinced me to go to
Europe I did it because suggestions
Australia left on my soil Jimmy
international travel but no I wait you
know and I went to Antwerp I went to I
did the same are you doing it was
Antwerp it was very gorgeous beautiful
right Copenhagen one with meringue so we
talked about you the whole week so you
convinced me to go over and I credited
you completely with being the finally
you just I just kept [ __ ] here and
you in my head and you were right I was
wrong and how yeah you suck tickets I
told I didn't sell out but it was better
than I thought it was going to be and
the crowds were great like the crowds it
came were great they got the jokes it
was they were everyone was lovely and
people tweet about it then you get on
people's netflix pages and Antwerp or
whatever and then you'll sell more
tickets and it'll be like you're going
to Buffalo okay I get to go to Europe
it's great like a paid vacation did you
hate though I hated traveling so much
and like I have a limit amount of times
we got to get back for this like you do
a show too
Thursday and then you get on the plane
Friday and then you do a show Friday
they get on the plane like I hate that's
the only things you can't enjoy the
cities yeah so what I do is I usually I
go over there before the tour starts and
I'll pick a city I want to be in and
I'll spend like four or five days you
know getting acclimated to the time and
all right and actually getting to do
some [ __ ] I want to do but you know
because I've had you know friends and
family members hey next time you do one
of those runs through Europe you know I
want to go with you and it's just like
you really don't you're gonna be like oh
you know there's the Roman Colosseum
then there it goes yeah I'm on a plane
again you know so yeah did you learn
like that but the first time you know
the first time I did it I I told you
know I told my wife you know okay I go
just hang in there on this one this is
going to be a thrash and she was totally
cool with it and I was like eventually
I'll sell tickets over here yeah and
we'll be able to do this more like a
vacation that's ended up what happened
yeah it does take these it takes a
couple of times through and you know he
was talking me about your first tour and
he's like it was great good then it got
great then he kind of met you know it's
just the way it works like you know they
get to know you a little over time but
it was the idea of just performing all
these places where you never think
people would know who you are and then
people show up it was a [ __ ] this is
pretty it was great happy I did it yeah
crowd I'm fully uh yeah that's good well
I'm glad you went over there had a good
time you didn't come back it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] in there no no I wish I had more
time if I didn't have radio I would
probably have stretched it out not that
a Monday show in Belgium I would've
probably stayed Monday done a Tuesday or
Wednesday show but you know you got to
do them on weird nights you like you'd
probably rather not work yeah yeah yeah
Antwerp was one of those places that I
wanted to spend like a week there and I
literally went there like drove in from
I didn't know where the hell it was
someplace in Germany just we drove in
all you drove and then did the you know
had one beer did this show and then left
the next day and that was one of those
places I just you know put a little pin
in pin in it come on all right one of
these times I'm going to [ __ ] hang
here for a few days we only have eight
minutes left before our show gets cut
off how is it being a father I've seen
you since then but we haven't had you on
the show oh it's it's it's great it's
been an amazing thing and the only thing
that I haven't enjoyed is talking to a
lot of parents
realizing well they just you know they
[ __ ] want to put anxiety on you oh
it's going good now wait till a couple
months yeah okay so I just I don't talk
to them but other than that it's been
tremendous she's amazing she's sitting
up now she laughs you know you know it's
funny my wife can make her laugh and I
can't I'm like bombing with my own I
like to steal and her jokes I feel it
her jokes to make a lot but now it takes
him like the baby wild to bond with the
guy because they have that immediate
connection with the mother immediately
skin-to-skin you know the right breast
feeding and everything and like the mom
is their world so it takes a while for
them you know they recognize you like oh
there's that that face I know and I feel
like in the last like you know ten days
she's kind of like looking at me as some
sort of entity that's in her life which
is pretty cool how old is she
five months first you serve no purpose
like you know obviously there's the food
and the whole thing but then what is
this person doing you did there's no
purpose they can see for you at first
and so they probably see a for a couple
of weeks and like all right these are
yeah yeah it's uh yeah no it was more a
few a few months well it's like the
first three months I mean they're just
sort of a cute little thing you're
carrying around and they're sort of
looking at you and not quite
understanding anything but somewhere in
like you know three and a half they
start to become this little person and
it took about five months well now I
just yeah really see her taking me in
like oh there's that guy I know that guy
did it change anything because you they
say it changes everything or I don't
I've never experienced it to change any
for you um what does it change
I don't know I yeah I never had like
that like oh my god everything's did I
just I get that you know that this
person I always have to take care of it
like that that whole like cloud clap
moment of I think I mean it was obvious
that that's what it was so and I'm also
like really [ __ ] shut down paved over
emotional guy so I think like when that
stuff comes out for me is not in normal
times I find like I don't like when my
daughter was born it wasn't this
immediate like oh my god it took like 15
hours what happened after like 15 hours
my wife played Stevie Wonder isn't she
lovely and then I thought about somebody
hurting her and I had this
murder is [ __ ] thought what I will do
to somebody really that's how I felt
unconditional love I think you gotta
come thinking about marriage
a murderous rage yeah and I don't know
if that means I'm [ __ ] up which I
probably am to some eunuch amis we're
like you know traumatic should happen to
us so like I think we feel [ __ ]
differently so I do know that the one
thing that has amazed me is how
effortless it is to take care of her
like I just catch myself being a dad
like for so many years I was just like I
don't think I can do this and all this
stuff but then it's just you know my
wife asked me to do stuff and it's like
not even like a questions like hey will
you do this like ask question I almost
get offended that she's asking sure like
why wouldn't I do that I love this kid
to death were you in the room during the
birth you stayed there in the room do
you glad you did you as you didn't know
I'm glad I did cuz you got to go in
there to support your wife I than that
you just try not to [ __ ] be in the
way it's really like it's the ultimate
third wheel everybody in there is
serving a purpose and you're sort of
standing like you never just feel like
you know you just never feel like more
like not like like worthy you know I
will tell you this one that's really
change before I go up and do stand-up
sets like more times than not I'm
scrolling through quick pictures looking
at her you are and I'm actually like
going like why I can't believe like what
what a softy I am I'm usually like you
know make sure you know your bits and
all that type of stuff and you know my
wife I always make sure she like sends
me pictures and stuff I don't do time I
know I'm a - I know I'm a changed person
but I'm - not in touch with my own
emotions to know how it is yet but the
change traveling I'll let you know yeah
it has and I'm actually going out to
dinner with my agent tonight and I'm
discussing how I want to do the road now
so I can possibly bring the two of them
see yourself [ __ ] out I am I just
told you how I was even aware in the
moment I scroll through pictures of it
before I go onstage I'm meeting with my
manager tonight to adjust how I do my
stand-up you know schedule now so yeah I
guess it's changed me to completely
changed me I just needed to talk it out
like I said I yeah I tend to downplay
[ __ ] so when you when you you want to go
out like less obviously or do you want
to go and stay in one place for a longer
period yeah like rather than play you
know the bigger place
play the smaller place for three nights
and then just turned into like a
mini-vacation guy kind of stay somewhere
I get more reps I don't burn out a city
I get to enjoy the city right doesn't
become like that Antwerp thing like you
know there's certain cities like you
know there's a bunch San Francisco
Seattle Portland Chicago Minneapolis
Nashville I got a lot of cities that I
love and would love to spend more than
just a day there right so this gives me
the excuse and then but then I also hate
like you know like the first time she
laughed I was on the road first time she
sat up I was on the road it's that bad I
come back like the next year and I see
it but it's also you know I don't want
to miss all of that and so this right
here is the longest I'm ever going to do
like this is a six day thing and it just
worked out because I'm promoting the
shelter I'm never doing that again and
that's what I'm talking to my agent
about like just as far as like I'm going
to do this [ __ ] because what's great
about being a comedian is as much as you
go on the road you actually spend more
time with your kid if you do it right
because even if I spend six days a month
on the road you know that's another 24
days I'm home and like you're home I
don't have like a 9:00 to 5:00 9:00 to
5:00 absolutely I've days of [ __ ]
week plus the traffic and you miss a lot
of that stuff anyway because you'd be at
work like a lot of stuff 9:00 to 5:00
you missed the first laugh or stuff
because your wife's home during the day
so yeah yeah you take the kid with you
that's great yeah not dude she's good
she's [ __ ] awesome so you get them
flown with yet no I haven't and I'm kind
of don't want it my wife's like Nana
it's not a big deal I don't like flying
with a kid when you can't explain to
them how to clear their ears Yeah right
I don't think that's fair to the kid you
know what I could don't want to do that
just looking at them like walking uh
yeah they have no idea they don't know
that you're there yep kiai every
three-month-old okay okay so you haven't
flown in congratulations well thank you
congratulations to you yeah we're
getting cut off in one minute because
the computer stops us it's not that we
can keep talking about that we can't
okay um so bill is promoting season 2 of
f is for family it's now streaming on
Netflix it's 10 episodes you can get all
of them right now
that's a beautiful thing by Netflix
people don't have to like wait 8 weeks
for your [ __ ] to come out I can just
watch it and keep watching it right yeah
I know else is great it takes you a year
to make it they watch it 5
and then they go what's the next season
yeah yeah and then you got to start the
whole [ __ ] promotion thing over again
yeah it's been I wish you wish you could
make them as fast as people could watch
them
yeah did you ever wish that it was like
more weekly I guess do you ever wish
that it was it was spread out a little
bit would that be easier
um yeah in a way cuz it's kind of like
you know if you got a really thoughtful
gift for somebody and they just sort of
devour you cook a meal for somebody they
just [ __ ] devour it as opposed to
like enjoying and go oh my god oh and
the side dish oh and this and the glass
of wine yeah ah belch and ask when's
dessert it doesn't seem to hurt it
though like I go it doesn't it doesn't I
go through things man I just watched the
keeper documenter and it's like I Platt
through it in two days but I'm still
thinking of it I'm still talking about
like you know people it doesn't mean
that they forget about your project they
don't still talk about it and still
think about it like they've watched it
for 12 straight weeks that's true yeah
because everyone starts discovery and
they start talking about it they always
talk about it more because they've got a
complete thought process to get behind
not just trying to analyse my love you
guys positive attitude towards the
future yeah I know I mean I'm feeling
more positive guys are all about it
screaming that's it all your [ __ ] out
there I know right
I know I don't like to believe it a nice
time you hear about me I'm going to be
[ __ ] hang myself in a closet this is
best for now yeah do you pull it from
you put all your [ __ ] out there yeah yes
you're interesting [ __ ] would be like
hey you want to go to the mall or
whatever and see holding hands with a
genetic girl we're going to cut a bill I
love you and I wish you a lot of time
with you yeah access for family you'll
be brilliant got to introduce my Andrew
thumbless he does my podcast today hi
Andrew how are you oh man
so he's just came in to say hello he's a
bit shy so nice meeting you and it's
good seeing you again maybe I'll see you
this week if you're in town for six days
every day okay guys thank you